[Musik]
leute gleich beginnt die erste wahl
folge bei der ich alleine bin und wie
soll ich sagen ich habe fehler beim
aufnehmen gemacht und deshalb war luca
total leise und ich halte karl aut und
ich musste gerade im schnitt irgendwie
probieren dass man luca halt versteht
überhaupt und das klingt leider nicht
ganz so toll und weiß auch schon total
spät ist habe ich auch nicht so viel
zeit gehabt das video großartig zu
bearbeiten ich hoffe mal dass ich mir da
nicht sauer sein oder ich irgendwie euch
enttäuscht habe wenn ihr gerade
abonniert habt und meine folgen zu
schauen aber ja dann beginnen wir mit
der ersten folge wo ich alleine bin
jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen
zur ersten wahl folge bei der ich
zumindest im spiel alleine bin
hey luca hallo luther kommentiert immer
noch mit ich gebe auf dem server sind
zwei leute drauf kaka ich hier und
selbstgespräch ich könnte jetzt
eingebaut werden sein nein bin ich nicht
okay sehr überraschend ok ich kann mich
nicht bewegen
ich kann nicht sehen kleinere herget und
amerika hinterher noch nicht zumindest
mein plan ist jetzt folgen der leute
hier noch ein bisschen essen schnitzel
also übrigens falls ihr euch fragt warum
ich mich so wundert dass ich das kann
hinterher joint ich bin aktuell gegangen
also jeder von den teilnehmern konnte
meine aktuelle folge sehen aber
anscheinend fand keiner interessant
genug mich zu sniper oder so deshalb bin
ich ein bisschen überrascht jetzt dass
keiner mich umbringt aber für den fall
hat sich auch vorbereitet habe ich mich
auch vorgesorgt meine ich und zwar werde
ich jetzt zum spawn gehen es sei denn
die finte jetzt irgendwie was krasses
dass eine schlucht
man sollte vielleicht mal reinschauen in
die schlucht aber es ist immer noch
keine autos aber da ist in zwei auf dem
server aber alle beiden nicht bei mir
wäre ich dann auch noch sara takanashi
uns selbst gespräch
ja weil ich jetzt auch nicht wir sind
also ich schaue auch selber keine
anderen wahrer folgen muss ich zugeben
ja ist genauso am wenigsten verdient zu
gewinnen
ich habe nein also ich glaube wir hatten
ja auch beide nie den anspruch zu
gewinnen wir wollten einfach ein
bisschen überleben und falls wir irgend
jemanden wählen würden wäre es halt ein
weltwunder
aber na ja also ich werde mal schauen
ich bin hier jetzt gerade bei 24 der des
born ist bei 0 0 0 0 des ponys bei ich
weiß nicht wie ich auch um die null
koordinate okay nicht genau bei null
aber da wird sich das schon irgendwie
finde ich glaub ich mach mal ganz kurzen
abstecher in diese in die schlucht hier
einfach weil es einfach schade wäre
falls ich jetzt irgendwas krasses finde
so krass es geht direkt runter dann
schauen wir doch mal love ist zum
beispiel schon mal ganz wertvoll
luca wir haben uns ja was überlegt wir
haben bzw
ich habe den kommentaren gefragt ob die
leute noch changes sehen wollen und die
antwort war ganz eindeutig ja
und deshalb hat luca sich die magische
miesmuschel extra heruntergeladen
ja stimmt gar nicht ganz wichtig so
sollte ich keine ahnung dieses was weiß
ich dieses auto kaufen erstmal magische
miesmuschel app oder soll die schlafen
gehen
die ich jetzt auf toilette gehen oder
die schalte noch kurz in meinem körper
behalten
viele komische vista behindert meine
folge nur deshalb raus jetzt keinen mist
ok sehr gut dann frag mal die magische
miesmuschel ab ob ich mir in lava einmal
machen soll
ok nein ich darf nicht da hab ich nicht
eine bitte ich darf jetzt mir kein lager
einmal machen darfst du nicht nur
scheiße was sie nun liege jedoch oder um
es nur which die werde ich erst mal auf
distanz gehen
was hat ob die kinder hast ich habe sie
schon getötet durftest du sie töten
durfte makatsch töten durfte maxi mit
töten
ich kann nicht mehr drüber nachdenken
ich hab' ich habe sie getötet muss ich
jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung habe ich
eine strafe verdient
diesmal keine strafe das ist das ist
schon was wert leute ich hatte schon ein
bisschen angst dass ich jetzt mit irgend
einer strafe rechnen muss
die magische 43 prozent akku ladekabel
okay beeil dich lustig wenn ich jetzt
ein skelett töten würde
ich habe auch einen bogen bitte nicht
darauf ein
hast du davon so ok ich weiß gar nicht
so genau
ja wie gesagt lassen hat jetzt erst mal
mein ziel da oben gibt es eisen diaz hat
einfach damit ich mir einen crafting
table krawinkel solch ein statement
table machen kann weil ich wirklich
gerne
falls ich jetzt schon alleine weiter
kämpfe wenigstens gut eclipse sein will
ich meine ich habe jetzt ein paar folgen
von den anderen beziehungsweise den
titel the ship titel und erfolge von
jemand anders gesehen was was sagt das
über mich und uns alle tief
eigentlich ist das der inbegriff von
team baut würde ich hier und zwar hat er
nämlich einer in folge drei wohlgemerkt
eine schärfe 3 und feiere aspect 1
schwert gehabt und wir freuen uns so
yeah ich meine ich hab letzte folge in
folge die folge war dass folge 5 habe
ich das voll bekommen naja was solls ok
bisschen kopflos werden darf max koppel
loswerden
sorry ich hab schon weggeworfen total
blöd muss wieder einsammeln bis aber in
der laber muss jetzt in die lava gehen
ok muss wachsen die lava gehen
ok möglich weiter fragen wären hätten
wir nicht
ich hätte keine andere wahl gehabt auf
welcher höhe gibt's nochmal die us elf
klopp-elf ist
ich glaube es ist eine gute höhe und ich
bin nicht gerade auf höhe 11
astrid mining nötig denn aus ich freue
mich hier nur in der höhle ab und zu mal
in die wand rein um zu gucken ob ich
vielleicht erfolg habe
frag mal die magische miesmuschel ob ich
weiter nach dir suchen solle einfach zu
umgehen
ja das ist keine jahre allein frage soll
soll ich weiter die us suchen okay das
mache ich diese scheiß vielleicht fragen
aus und mache jetzt nur positiv und
negativ macht ihm nun negativ rein so
richtig kenne ich hab wirklich positiv
und negativ also solltest du ja mal
versuchen ja schon
immerhin soll ich die diamanten ansporn
suchen erwarte ok na gut dann werde ich
ja hier mal ein paar einbauen einpacken
müssen sage ich mal
weil die magische miesmuschel dass sie
ihre kisten gelagert hatte bitte bagdad
die ganzen sachen die wir in unseren
kisten gelagert haben ja unsere ganzen
kisten alter wir werden 10 stück oder so
hier gibt es auch eine neue höhle
da habe ich die kurze erforschen
magische miesmuschel okay hey ich dachte
dass vielleicht antworten heraus gemacht
habe ich aber ich glaube das sollte
positiv einfach sein aber ich frag doch
mal darf er die höhle erforschen erfasst
mein gott oh mein gott jahr wie dumm ist
nicht zu machen
auch bitte bitte sagen mal dass das die
ersten beiden waren positiv ok ich
dachte schon fertig du fragst du immer
so schön nachname ist die magische mir
keinen bock mehr drauf hat luca kaum
bist du tot hänge sind jetzt schon den
halter
mann mann mann mann mann die höhle ist
eigentlich echt supreme weil ich hier
alles was ich irgendwie brauchen könnte
lab ist es schon mal gut falls ich
verzaubern kann irgendwann die us waren
halt drei creeper einfach reif reaper
könnte ich mir nen schönen tnt falle
mitmachen
komm schon ein paar diaz werden einfach
der hammer alter weil ich mein ich will
ja echt jetzt nicht so auf über safe
spielen ganz war aber ich hätte schon
bock einfach ein paar chancen zu haben
indem ich mir halt einfach keine ahnung
schärfe schwerte oder so was machen kann
so traurig das ist alleine noch nicht
doch auch lose okay hier ist aber nichts
in der höhle finde ich jetzt gar nicht
die zeit zum strip nach zeit und lust am
schwimmen habe ich halt einfach nicht so
ich habe zehn minuten schon aufgenommen
dann begebe ich mich jetzt einmal ums
bauen darf sich max zum sparen gegeben
ok dadurch wenigstens in die richtung
von bord gehen
unwahrscheinlich aber auch unmöglich
okay es ist vielleicht auch nicht so
schlau was wir dort machen weil es ist
nacht und da oben können überall monster
sein die wirklich beschützen magische
möchtest du max beschützen
danke oh mein gott oh mein gott ich kann
man so crazy drauf sein
ein pferd ok naja also ab zum spot die
richtung ist ganz gut hier in die ich
mich bewege okay okay ich bewege mich
auf den sport
da bin ich jetzt einfach mal hin hol mir
noch ein paar münchen nebenbei einfach
weil essen schnell runter luca nur weil
wir jetzt keine fehler mehr machen muss
brauchst du nicht hier während der
größte spaß
ach ja ach ja redet sie nur an die guten
alten zeiten in denen wir waren videos
gemacht haben zusammen die magische
miesmuschel erinnert sich und du kannst
du dir auch kopf hoch
wenn ich hier noch irgendeiner höhle
finde auf den weg darf ich die
erforschen ok darauf davon ist der spot
da habe ich eine höhle erforschen wenn
ich eine finde sehr gut da ich mich auch
einfach unter dem spawn runter bauen
[Musik]
gamescom haben schon irgendwelche faxen
gemacht wo irgend wie man das so in rage
dass er sich damit runter bauen kann
100 gibt es ja auch fallen haben s bahn
ich lasse das lieber
ich glaube ich gehe mal ganz kurz in den
neckar einfach damit ich mal ein netter
war dann gehe ich sofort wieder raus und
kann ich sagen ich war bei waren etwa
und du nicht luca so luca ich war bei
werder und du nicht wirklich dazu
überhaupt warten miesmuschel ich durfte
nicht man muss jetzt wieder rückwärts
reingehen doch meine letzte damit was
zurück gemacht sagt sagt die miesmuschel
das auch was du musst in frage stellen
die haben miesmuschel muss ich noch mal
rückwärts in den äther gehen
ja ich bin rückwärts im netz und gerade
auch geradeaus zurück näher rückt alles
okay okay und den rückwärts raus aus dem
bett hatte das gleich als
wiedergutmachung
gut möglich oder unmöglich nicht möglich
hat sie gesagt nun ein
naja ich mir jetzt auch egal er wirklich
ist es mir jetzt halt wirklich langsam
egal weil ich meine die magische
miesmuschel halte ich ja wirklich in
ehren aber okay ja ich will man nicht so
übermütig sein ich baue wenigstens
ehrlich bei mir hin so das ist halt
schon ein bisschen dreist von mir so
einfach zu ignorieren was die
miesmuschel mir sagt aber irgendwo muss
halt auch schauen wo ich bleibe in war
ohne ja ich werde jetzt strikt nach der
taktik von diamanten in fünf minuten von
crafter wie kannst du sagen hast du
gesehen dass ich dann dein altes video
eingeblendet ich habe eine folge doch
nicht gesehen ich war die ganze es war
richtig lustig ich habe deine als film
mit den wäscheklammern geredet haben
habe ich deine habe ich da eine alte
folge eingeblendet
acht perfekt wie du sowieso rede ist mit
seiner nasalen stimme unterstützen ist
sehr lustig nutzt okay so war und
bereits schon kurbeln ich bin jetzt
direkt und am spot da gibt's
lustigerweise eine höhle
hoffentlich gibts ja auch die ad hoc
wobei das kann natürlich sein wo ihr
wasser und links aufeinander getroffen
sind
ich wäre sehr schön ein paar diamant ost
zu finden
es moderiert maxime der folge auch
diamanten finden
ich hatte echt gehofft dass ich welche
kriegen würde ja ich bin auch wieder für
elf ist okay aber mir ist lieber sähe
krankhafter wird in 30 sekunden gekickt
bitte magische miesmuschel wenig noch
einen einzigen diamanten 30 sekunden man
hoffen kann
okay das war love ist gut warum gehe ich
überhaupt davon also warum ich überhaupt
in erwägung dass ich noch diamanten
finden wenn die magische miesmuschel
brings aufgeben
lohnt sich überhaupt noch warm zu
spielen fraktionierten ja okay also
warum spielen lohnt sich noch
ich würde es auch gekickt leute ich
hoffe mal die folge hat euch gefallen
es ist jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung so
alleine ein bisschen traurig aber was
kann ich mehr machen als einfach ein
paar sachen zu suchen und hoffen dass
ich welche finde
naja das war s max kruse